hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast rapid their use
interpretation and recording using the
Cajun knowledge base and hydrogen
clinical insight interpret presented by
Jennifer Poitras PhD principal genome
spica hi Jen I am Christina Mahalo -
blabbers and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we are excited to bring
you this educational web seminars
presented by labyrinth and sponsored by
kaya genj for more information about our
sponsor visit kaya Jen calm before we
begin I'd like to remind everyone that
this event is interactive we encourage
you to participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located in the
lower left of the presentation window
and type your question into the box that
appears on the screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation also please notice that you
will be viewing the presentation in the
slide window to enlarge the window just
click on the screen icon located on the
lower right if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of the presentation window or use the
Q&A button to let us know that you're
having a problem
this presentation is educational Ms
offers continuing education credits
please click on the button in the bottom
left corner and follow the process to
obtain your credit now please join me in
welcoming dr. Corr trip are they now
turn the presentation over to her great
thank you so much Kachina for that
introduction and for the opportunity to
speak to all of you today so first by
the way of the agenda first I'll go
through an introduction to the kaijin
knowledge base then introduce our kaijin
clinical insight interpret tool and
demonstrate how the knowledge base
underlying it enables rapid and accurate
variant interpretation then also the
tool
with a clinical exome use case where the
probe and has two unaffected parents and
is exhibiting a constellation of
features and through using the knowledge
base within QC I interpret we were able
to rapidly identify and report a
pathogenic candidate causal variant so
we're really going to be focusing on the
tertiary announced or on the
interpretation portion of this at the
end of the pipeline here but just to put
things in context so the goal really
occassion is to take us from sample to
insight so we do offer a wide variety
and you're likely familiar with our DNA
and RNA extraction kits as well as some
library preparation kids to prepare you
to perform your next-generation
sequencing but once you've generated all
those fast queue files you can easily
feed those into our bio medical genomics
workbench and this is a graphical user
interface application that's truly a
one-stop shop for
NGS analysis empowering the scientist or
clinician with really limited
bioinformatics knowledge to map reads to
the reference and for the purposes of
today's discussion call variance to
produce a VCF file which brings me to
the topics that I'll discuss today on
how we can leverage our curated content
within our downstream tools here
particularly Kaizen clinical insight
which is our clinical decision support
platform to rapidly distill this list of
variants down to one or a handful that
are likely implicated in the patient's
disease so the end result using this
archived and clinical insight interpret
tool is a report with a relevant variant
information including are automatically
classified variants based on the ACMG
guidelines as well as other relevant
pieces of information about your
variants including selected citations
that are relevant to this variant from
the literature and other externally
hosted websites additionally you'll see
that there's a well written very small
here but I'll cover this later in the
talk a number of data sources that
really come together to culminate in the
knowledge base that really gives us the
power to generate such a report
so accurate really look the crux of this
whole thing is the accurate variant
interpretation is really no small
undertaking so in order to align with
the ACMG guidelines and truly assess the
pathogenicity of a variant several
resources are necessary for gathering
information so I just highlighted a
handful here but we need to sit through
your variant specific publications and
then go through and look at on public
and proprietary databases to say okay
has my variant you know been seen before
in the public domain and and has it been
seen in the context of my particular
disease context additionally we can look
for things like you know variant
frequency or allele frequency in the
general population as well as bringing
in silico predictors all to come
together to get this variant
classification now there are really two
main challenges that are faced here one
is you know the challenge of efficiency
because first of all you're going
through and looking at all these
different pieces of information
independently so this is obviously
laborious and time-consuming and then
the second is one of accuracy as with
you know any manual process it can
definitely be arable error-prone so
kaijin has really simplified this
process by integrating and centralizing
all this information into what's now
known a world ingenuity but really now
kaijin knowledgebase so for the past 18
years we've had MD and PhD level
scientists manually curating the
literature and inputting findings in a
very controlled and meticulous way now
beyond the literature we also
incorporate data from third party
sources like clinical old child kaavo
mem and clinvar together to build this
ontology such that we now have this rich
resource of gene gene and gene phenotype
relationships on that you'll see in a
moment will enable us to easily pull out
variants of interest from a clinical
exome so I'll point out specific sources
within the knowledgebase later in the
talk but here especially on the left
hand side you'll see that there are
several data sources that we've included
here in our variant analysis and
prioritization tools but I wanted
specifically
to point out the recent inclusion of sin
OMG which we're really excited about as
it's the world's largest mutation
database for rare diseases
so all these variants are coming from
the Sena gene genetic testing service so
all variants are annotated using the
same in health pipeline and associated
with the phenotype so if the variant in
your sample that comes through in our
tool its present in sento MD you'll be
able to link out to it through a link
and then you can investigate on the
allele frequency of your variant of
interest in the Center MD patient
population and look at associated
phenotypes and pathogenicity so this is
you know one tremendous resource among
you know you can see a number of other
resources that are really coming
together to build the knowledge base and
the framework underlying our tools so
I'm we talked a lot conceptually about
our content but let's take a look at the
breadth of the coverage in terms of
numbers so our knowledge base not only
contains on two of the most common
frequently and most prevalently used
clinical mutation databases of with
clinical relevance but you can also
appreciate how much value is added from
our unique curated content from the
literature as we're adding you know 121
you know more genes in addition to
what's already in hgmd and clinvar in
our knowledge base and additionally in
terms of variants were increasing just
by adding our own
curated content 159 percent more
variants in addition to what's already
in clinvar and hgmd so you can see the
tremendous breadth and depth of coverage
that were offering by including our
manually curated content as well as
those in clinvar hgmd and other sources
as well so to illustrate how extensive
our variant coverage and our content is
so council is a health technology
company that offers carrier screening
and hereditary cancer risk assessment
and last month at the American Society
of Human Genetics meeting counsel
presented their findings in a poster
from an evaluation they performed and
the goal of this evaluation was to
assess whether a utilization of hyejin's
variant specific bibliographies within
qci
could match the level of accuracy and
quality of councils you know in-house
manual curation and pipeline so it looks
at around 2000 variants that they
reviewed over a three-month period and
in the graph on the left you can
appreciate the comprehensive nature of
our content where there's a tremendous
amount of overlap between you know
variant specific publications in the
council database as well as the batting
cage and as you can see there aren't
very many they're unique to Council at
all that you can see the tremendous
number of variant article pairs that are
added with the use of the kaijin
knowledgebase in addition to this you
can see that there was a tremendous
amount of time saved and looking at
variant specific publications and
searching for these publications which
you can really appreciate more fully and
the you know median sort of graph where
the amount of time spent searching for
variant specific publications was
decreased by an order of magnitude when
using qci so overall council
demonstrated there was really clearly a
value in adopting QC I interpret on into
their variant interpretation pipeline
and they've now made it a key component
of their variant Assessment pipeline
because they felt so strongly that it
added tremendous value so we've talked a
lot about the content in the knowledge
base and the variant specific content
that underlies QC III
so now we'll see the tool in action in a
clinical exome use case so this case was
actually published last year in BMC
genomics and in this trio the program
has two unaffected parents and is
exhibiting a constellation of features
that are included here but there was no
real clear diagnosis so to identify the
causal variant whole exome sequencing
was performed in all three individuals
in the Kindred so analysis of the fast Q
files was performed in a separate
platform upstream of this and produced a
VCF with around 6 million or greater
than 6 million variants now to the
others number down to something more
manageable we can utilize our variant
filtering tool ingenuity variant
analysis
where we filter based on evidence-based
implications in the knowledge base so we
filtered based on things like call
quality as well as frequency in nomads
and other publicly available databases
these are also resources that are
underlying the knowledge base and then
as you'll see when we get more into QC I
interpret we do automatically compute
the ACMG
using ACMG guidelines we computed and
classified on pathogenicity so we can
filter based on saying I only want to
keep variance in my lists that are
pathogenic or likely pathogenic based on
those guidelines and then finally
because we're presuming that this is you
know a de novo event and a de novo
mutation in my case or in the probe and
we've then filtered to look at variants
that are exclusively or independently
present in my case sample so in this row
right here and then absent in my control
samples are my two parents so you can
see the indicated by you know these two
dashes meaning that particular variant
is present in my program and then absent
in my control samples so now in just a
matter of minutes using this filtering
cascade and the underlying content that
we're pulling from these external
databases and also you know information
from the knowledge base which allows us
to impute or to classify variants based
on the ACMG guidelines we've gone from
over 6 million variants to just 21
variants which is something very
manageable which we're able to now
export and we're ready to assess and
report out on some of these variants so
using the export function we can now
export this short list of 21 variants
over to QC I interpret for analysis and
assessment so you can see is sort of
grayed out in the background within QC
III you'll sell out some basic pieces of
information including the patient name
on the test date and the you know SKU
for the tests being performed and again
we can leverage the information in the
knowledge base to
further filter and prioritize variance
based on the relationship with a
particular diagnosis if that's
appropriate or a constellation of
features which you know I've typed in
here so these can be hpo ideas as you
can see you can upload a file with these
hpo ideas or we can just simply type in
our constellation of features so this
will apply and will make more sense in
the next slide a phenotype driven
ranking algorithm of my variants to
identify candidate diseases associated
with these phenotypes and then relevant
variants in the patient that are
associated with those candidate diseases
so now I've uploaded all my BCS from
Berrien analysis and added the relevant
information so I'm ready to look at my
variant assessment so after applying the
phenotype driven ranking algorithm we
arrive at this list of just six variants
that you can see here that are ranked
based on the likelihood that the
candidate disease which is present in
this column is explained by the
phenotypes I entered which are
represented I entered five phenotypes so
this Rubinstein on TV syndrome type one
actually it has a connection or
relationship with each of the five
phenotypes that I entered so where a
ranks you know based on the likelihood
that the candidate disease is explained
by these phenotypes and has a
relationship with a variant from my VCF
file so using this approach we
prioritize this EP 300 to be the most
likely causal variant with a candidate
diagnosis of Rubinstein TV syndrome type
1 and again it's these genotype
phenotype relationships and the
phenotypic ontology is curated within
the knowledgebase that enables this kind
of prioritization without the content
used in filtering we never would have
arrived at this strong candidate
variance so quickly and this again was
all accomplished in a matter of minutes
so I just wanted to point out a few key
attributes here including the automated
a CMG classification so you can see that
this variant is classified as pathogenic
and I'll show you in an upcoming slide
you know exactly what rules were
triggered and we give you and provide
all the information to keep things as
transparent as possible you know
precisely how we arrived at this
pathogenic classification and we do this
using again the information in the
knowledge based on to apply those
guidelines again you know just
reiterating we also are ranking based on
phenotypes which is a clear you know
it's not necessary but it's definitely a
clear advantage of the underlying
knowledge in the knowledge base that we
can rank a prioritize these variants
based on these known relationships
between variants and phenotypes and then
finally you can see we can do some
further filtering based on again the
classification so you see in this short
list of six that has a connection with
my my phenotypes that I entered only one
of them is actually predicted to be
pathogenic but we can go through and
investigate the others you can see that
there are on both pathogenic which is my
one pathogenic variant in my list as
well as a number of variants of
uncertain significance so as I mentioned
we leverage the knowledge base to
automatically compute the ACMG
classification and show you which rules
were triggered which you can see here
while maintaining the flexibility to add
or remove criteria which you can see
here so we can change the strength of
the evidence that we're perceiving
adding criteria as well as adding notes
and adding rationale here as well and
then furthermore you know as counsel has
demonstrated the great value we can also
view the bibliography so this is going
to show me various specific findings
when I click here on one of our
particular variant I'm investigating in
this case I'm investigating this
nonsense mutation in ep 300 and what we
see is there are twenty references for
this particular nonsense mutation from
the literature as well as links to omen
and hgmd which I haven't shown here but
you can see on that there these are some
citations from litter
and I can choose to add these to my
report by clicking on these little tiles
here so that I can you know customize
and see what information that I you know
make sense for me to see within the
report another you know key feature here
is you know I want this to trigger
something in it and learn you know have
I seen this variant before so we can see
prior lab observations where I can say
okay I've seen this nonsense mutation
before and I classified it or assesses
pathogenic and this was the particular
phenotype and the date that it was
signed out on so you can keep track of
you know the tracking of that variant
and how you've assessed it in the past
additionally reported case counts so in
other laboratories for example in ohm M
R sorry in clinvar you know has this
variant been seen and what was the
significance was it seen in an infected
individual or an unaffected individual
which can be a rich resource of
information when you're really trying to
prioritize and understand the potential
implications of these variants so again
with the example cases from other labs
and I mentioned sento MD so if there was
you know a citation or this variant was
present in that central empty patient
population there would be a link here as
well but all these links go to you know
the hgmd specific its accession clinvar
as well as cosmic or any of these other
external databases that we pull data
from for you to assess and investigate
you know what the scenario or the
context was underlying those variant
annotations and additionally again
because we have you know exact and of
course nomads and a number of other
population-based data pieces in the
knowledge base we could also look at you
know frequency of these variants for the
allele frequency and different
populations and sub stratify actually by
ethnicity as well which is a nice
feature if you're looking at a
particular ethnicity and finally
bringing an in silico predictor so we're
really in one place providing you with
all the information you would need to
assess your variant so finally you can
see if I'm oust over this CAD score I
could see that there's this variant
produces a CAD score of 38 which is
Tereus so I can integrate you know all
these pieces of information to make my
final assessment rather than having a
hunt around in several different places
so you can see here the final output is
going to be this report which has
several pieces of information from you
know the patient name and things that we
added it's very straightforward and this
is configurable so we can work with you
to configure this however you like but
it's very straightforward we show you
our reported out pathogenicity so I
stuck with the computer class
classification this is a pathogenic
variant based on ACMG guidelines in the
context of this phenotype this rumensin
baby syndrome type one we have other
information regarding the specific
protein changes and changes to the cDNA
and then finally you can see you know
what in these notes what version of the
knowledge base is being used and all of
the different you know builds of the
different databases and data types that
we're pulling from to come together and
build the knowledge base so if you keep
it consistent and know that when I you
know reported out this variant this was
the particular you know build with DB
snip that was used in the investment and
also you know I selected those certain
citations and things that were relevant
for me to know to include in this report
so we've got my hgmd accession number my
clinvar accession number and a number of
citations that are relevant to this
particular variant so within the Kaiser
knowledge base within QC I interpret
really facilitates two things so I hope
I've left you with today on the rapid
variant filtering and prioritization
which is essential using our curated
content so we can filter because we have
all these nomads in exact and NHLBI ESP
for example public databases underlying
the knowledge base we can filter based
on allele frequency in those databases
we can select for pathogenic and likely
pathogenic variants for example because
we do automatically
the ACMG guidelines using content from
within the knowledgebase and also we can
identify causal variants based on
relationships with phenotypes and
disease indications because again we
have these curated gene gene and gene
phenotype relationships they're really
enable us to uniquely are uniquely
position us to pull out these causal
variants based on these disease
indications that were entering and then
beyond that we also have the other
pieces the comprehensive variant
reporting because we do have our
automated ACMG variant classification
I've done for you that you also you know
it we also offer the the relaxedness of
it so you can actually add new rationale
and add different pieces of information
to change the assessment as well as our
various specific bibliographies so
rather than now hunting around and
looking in pubmed in several different
places like counsel was able to show
it's going to save a tremendous amount
of time and be more you know efficient
accurate because the depth of coverage
the breadth of coverage and the just
like overall content that we're
providing here with the variants
specific on findings so that's all I
have for you guys today I'm happy to
take any questions if there are any
thank you doctor portrait for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window type
your question into the box that appears
on the screen and click the send button
well if there's many questions as we
have time for so let's get started our
first question of the day app how often
is the content updated so that is a very
important question maybe I can pull up a
slide just to give it some context so I
mentioned that there were let me get rid
of that thing okay so I mentioned that
there were different sources of
information right so we've got our
expert findings which are manually
curated from the literature findings and
those are
updated on a weekly basis like pretty
much daily we're always putting in new
manually curated findings from the
literature I also mentioned that we
bring in a large number of third-party
data sources so these are your clinvar
and clinical trials.gov for example and
those are updated on a quarterly basis
and again it's pretty easy especially in
QC I interpret on to see you know what
builds were using sorry Lee you know the
issue of those external you can see the
full list of all the external data that
we're pulling in the builds for those as
well so again those are quarterly and
then all of our literature based content
is updated weekly thanks thank you
our next question asks how is the
content curated so again I can guess I
can go back to that sorry okay so we do
actually have full-time people whose job
it is or at least part-time to again at
the MD and PhD level to actually read
and using our controlled vocabulary put
in these expert findings but we also
have these expert assist findings which
uses the computer algorithm to go
through and pull out the major findings
of the finding would be kind of a
summary of the meat and potatoes of
what's in this article right like this
gene is associated with a particular
phenotype in a particular context so we
have a computer algorithm that does that
but always is a final QC step actual
scientists are looking at those findings
before they go in the knowledge base to
make sure that we have you know the
highest and best representative content
thank you for that answer our third
question of the day if I had if I have
seen a variance in my lab previous wage
will qci I flag at that varies yeah so
that's another really important feature
and note let me see here an important
functionality so sorry so you can see
here so for example in this EP 300
sample I do have this laboratory
observations key where it has actually
pointed out on the assessment where I
previously saw it the date where I
previously saw it on the in session ID
and the phenotype so I can say or feel
more confident that okay I reported this
out as pathogenic previously and a
particular phenotype of interest that
may or may not be close to what I'm
studying currently but you know at least
I have that information right in front
of me so yes it does excellent thank you
that was the last question I have for
the day thank you once again I would
also like to know dr. portrait if you
have any final comments you'd like to
leave audience with today I just really
hope that I have a pressed upon you on
the the fact that our content is really
second to none and we'll you know speed
up and make your variant reporting more
accurate additionally I just wanted to
point out that because I forgot to
mention this that we do integrate with
electronic record electronic medical
records mechanisms as well as like the
different limb systems so we can highly
you know configure eight this and
integrate this with whatever your
existing pipeline is to really
streamline your variant interpretation
and analysis excellent thank you so much
dr. Fletcher I would also like to thank
hydrogen for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone know that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand eeling
through February of 2018 you will
receive an email from libraries letting
you know when the webcast will be
available to replay please share that
announcement with your colleagues to may
have today's live event that's all for
now thank you for joining us and we hope
to see you again here soon at laborat
goodbye